and as ukraine's counter-offensive
continues to progress its foreign
minister has launched an unusually blunt
attack on germany
accusing berlin of ignoring pleas for
military hardware like battle tanks
disappointing signals from germany while
ukraine needs leopards and martyrs now
to be true coliba tweeted not a single
rational argument on why these weapons
cannot be supplied only abstract fears
and excuses
well let's get tobias bachelor's
perspective on this he's a member of the
german parliament for the greens the
party of foreign minister analina
bairbach welcome to dw news do you feel
foreign minister khulib's criticism is
aimed at you
i think it's aimed at the government and
i do understand um his feelings very
well i do believe um that we at certain
points uh
have a strong
support in
the german people for ukraine and at
certain points we can do more as a
government or the government can do more
and so i really understand and i see
that he's pointing
at us and at the government yes
chancellor olaf says he will not send
battle tanks to ukraine unless other
countries do the same he says germany
must not act unilaterally that's a fair
point isn't it
it's a fair point to say we must not act
on our own and i would rather say we
must act coordinated with our partners
our allies within nato but also with our
partners outside nato and this of course
includes ukraine so
um i would even argue the window we have
within this coordinated approach is a
bigger and i would say yes this also
includes the demand
of sending um
yes tanks as well
um and of course uh
i think there are two lines where we
need to see one is how can we support
ukraine in in their battle and
in the end the battle they are fighting
for us as well for freedom for democracy
and the other of course is what are we
able to deliver and of course i do see
and acknowledge that those are two
important arguments to be made but on
both hands i see more opportunities that
are possible for example to deliver the
martyrs on that
why is it though do you think that no
western ally has agreed to send battle
tanks yet when it's clear ukraine needs
them to keep its counter-offensive going
well i do see the point that first of
all this is a new category so i'm
completely in that this needs to be
discussed although this takes time i see
that
i think the other thing is that this is
again the second line i tried to
describe is what are we able to deliver
deliver what do we have in stock and i
think there's something um that we have
the argumentation around
well what do we have in stock in our
military and there's a new opportunity
now um i think it was uh today when
metal announced that they have in fact
restored 16 old motor tanks um and i
think this is another opportunity now
which i do totally understand makes up a
new window um which hasn't been there
before uh or took a while to create and
um therefore i see that this is a bit of
another discussion now
because it's not about what what do we
have in stock what our own militaries
actually need it it sounds like uh
there's a lot of discussion going on
whether or not it's the right discussion
is another question but time is of the
essence here in ukraine what's your
party going to do to convince your
coalition partner to change course
well we've been arguing with them for
the last few weeks and months i would
say and we will continue that of course
it's a
a discussion which is very much done or
created within the committee of defense
but also from a for agent perspective i
really believe it's important um to
stress the argument that we need to
stand at the sides of those who fight
for the liberal cause fight for our
values and otherwise we lose other
partners in the world um and i think to
stay consistent at that point it's it's
a thing we can only try to explain again
and again
besides losing other partners around the
world over this squabbling is this
something
that could really not only divide the
german government which it's already
doing but also bring down
the german government
no because i don't see any alternatives
lying there in the political field i i
do believe that as certain
recent surveys showed the the support
for in within the german people for
ukraine is huge and
people demand more um so i don't really
see that this government can find a way
around doing that but also when i look
at the political landscape i think this
might be the wrong fear of the wrong
political forces
within within now not
pushing forward
so i don't really see an alternative
there i don't see anyone being
consistently
and
advocating to someone else who isn't in
the government right now of course the
conservatives do but i'm skeptical about
them delivering um well more consistent
when you look at the bigger picture and
how to uh well get more surren and
independent also regarding the energy
crisis we have right now from russia so
i don't really see an alternative there
we're stuck with the best we have um
also of course we need to push further
german lawmaker with the green party
thank you for coming on the show today
let's talk to johannes aid he's a member
of the german parliament for the social
democrats thanks for being on dw
do you share that criticism from the
ukrainian foreign minister
i don't share the this
statement from the ukrainian foreign
minister we deliver a lot so we have
delivered military equipment for more
than 600 million euros to the ukraine
from the industry as well also from the
forces and i think that our strategy to
provide the ukraine with equipment as it
hits the russian superiorities like
firepower artillery
has proven quite well um that it works
delivering a lot in your words but why
then does ukraine
and from day one of this war continually
plead for more
uh ukraine is in a very deteriorated
situation and they have to defend
themselves themselves they
fight for survival and
sure it's a situation where you will ask
for more on where you'll ask always for
more support but actually we have forces
that were
saved down to a level uh where we can
hardly grant our national defense
capabilities and our commitments to nato
so we can just give what we have
germany's defensive position is uh a
completely different story though and
that has its uh it's its background over
the past years i would say the situation
now is that uh ukraine is being attacked
um
why can't more be sent and and why not
heavier equipment as well
um we will not act alone so we will
always act in a
multilateral environment and as you
probably can see there was delivered no
western battle tank to ukraine from any
major european country
and this is an agreement what we follow
and i think it serves as well
so germany's not in a position to lead
the way as europe's biggest and richest
economy
we have also commitments to nato as i
told you and we have reduced our numbers
of battle tanks and military equipments
so dramatically that we have to work
with the capability reserve we have to
keep for our own purposes
and until this reserve we deliver what
we can
i understand there are different
opinions within the spd why
are the social democrats so divided when
it comes to military support for ukraine
i'm a career officer myself but i can
tell you i think that our reasoned and
well-thought-out approach to this to
deliver capabilities ukrainians can use
and then the same way does not weaken
our national defense is the right way to
go for our country
genocide german lawmaker with the social
democratic party thank you very much for
joining us here on dw news
well ukraine's military successes come
as the west supplies it with weapons but
there are alternative ways to support
the war effort that don't involve
conventional weapons and many ukrainians
are involved in deploying them as dw's
matthias bullinger reports
a normal car can carry several of them
and stay safely behind the front line
they're small and easy to transport
but this box doesn't contain a piece of
sophisticated military tech
it's a simple drone that could be bought
in any electronics shop around the world
here in ukraine they have become an
important tool in the wharf
we use these consumer drones because
they have good cameras and good
technical specifications
the only thing we do
is remove some of the limitations from
the software
drones like these often have limits on
their speed altitude or range sometimes
their systems also block them from
places like airports
ukrainian programmers hack the software
to remove these limits and send them
into enemy territory
it's much cheaper and safer than
traditional aerial reconnaissance
our goal is to identify the enemy
if possible in real time
so we can guarantee we hit the target
we've seen without harming civilians
aerial pictures like these showing
strikes have become common in this war
both sides use essentially the same
drones but the ukrainians say they've
had a disadvantage
most consumer drones are made by the
chinese company dji which also makes a
tool called aeroscope to track drones
and their pilots
ukraine says dji only gives it to the
russians
aeroscope can see which model and the
coordinates of the drone its trajectory
and also the starting point where it
will return to when called back
the reconnaissance unit gives these
coordinates to the artillery so they can
target the pilot
dji denies favoring the russians and
ukrainian army hackers are now
reprogramming the drones so they can't
be detected
they've even developed gadgets so the
drones can drop small explosives